this is a production of Cornell
University
great turnout and obviously a lot of
interest in this topic so today we're
happy to welcome back Aaron marty'll who
is a graduate student in our department
here you can avoid start who graduated
the MPSF public garden leadership in
2010 and received a career award went
off to study permaculture might be
integrated into public gardens month ago
had a great experience we got wonderful
letters from Australia New Zealand and
Trinidad and so she's here to tell you
about her experiences and hope you know
about the questions and for the cards
for ok I actually yeah you can start all
right can you take your life the cards
are for some feedback I can't do this
without getting a little bit of feedback
from you and this is a method called
Street top once i get the class of the
other get to delta or triangle so
through the course of the top if you can
just jot down one thing that you've
learned and one thing that
so there is a quiz whereas that's not
the quick so we have a short time today
we haven't laughed coming in at 115 it's
a gargantuan task to pack six months
worth of travel into 45 minutes which is
my goal so I want to point out my
website i blogged most of the time that
i was traveling it's permaculture hyphen
EDD com so if you have interest in
reading more about what I'm going to
touch on today this is a great place to
do that there's no way I can cover
everything so just pulled out some
highlights and some points for
discussion alright so this is acquitted
actually hope we've all had a little
time to consider this quickly and web
screen about a chicken and I'm not going
to ask for your inches now that I will
shortly so I want you to think about
that and I'll come back to it so the
title of my talk today is discovering
permaculture and public garden education
what I really want to do is talk about
what the contemporary context is where
these two different fields are
intersecting and before I get into that
I want to give you a little bit of
background and share my inspiration
in the summer of two thousand nine I did
an internship at durban botanic gardens
in South Africa and there my main task
was to develop the school program in the
purple corset dark so i worked with
about six school groups from ages 5 all
the way up to high school and i ran a
pretty intensive two and a half hour
program that was fairly standard
although we modified it for the age
group this program engaged the learners
on a level that was deeper and broader
than i've experienced before with
students i should say that during my
master's program in public art and
leadership my real focus with on
education and outreach so this is my
background and this is what i come to
this work with so just to give you a
quick overview of what the program was
to sort of set the stage for the rest of
my travels this past year students would
start in the permaculture garden and
they would get a card that had a
permaculture principle and they split up
into groups and they go out into the
garden and look for examples of doc
principal to share with the rest of the
group so everyone mr. discovering
exploring this was before any lessons
had taken place this was really just
about them getting out into space that
was followed by a tour by the garden
manager who would point out in more
detail the elements of the permaculture
garden and how those elements work
together to create something much larger
than each individual element
from their students did to intensive
hands-on soil science experiments really
engaging with their teachers who are
very involved with the process we talked
about compost how to compost also how to
feed the soil with compost how to
generate your own soil fertility rites
with the materials that you already have
looking at ways as a resource so in this
picture the students are learning about
compost while they're eating their fruit
snacks reflecting the fruit peels and
they are then immediately going out into
the garden collecting pumphrey other
green beans and other dry materials from
the garden and composting it straight
away so there's this very immediate
connection between what they're learning
in their classroom and how they see it
put into practice after that they stay
out in the garden and transform a patch
and sawed into a working garden bed and
they do this by sheet mulching with
cardboard and a lot of work out in
modern evil Lucas Oil to the point where
they can plant it that day and this
whole process takes place over the
course of about two hours they pair up
with a friend and they learn about
companion planting and friends and how
plants work together and create good
little ecosystems and how one plant can
help attract you know beneficial insects
and pests predators while another might
make particular nutrients more available
or shade of method that we will so
during this experience of working
closely with developing the program and
evaluating it through my
observation and also through surveys
with the students and the teachers I
realized that there is something very
powerful here in terms of helping you
make the connection with what they're
doing in the garden and what's happening
really in the environment what's
happening
so that curiosity really continued and I
saw it being so effective in this
learning environment in the permaculture
garden I was curious as to what other
public gardens out there have a similar
program or engage with permaculture in
some way so that's when I became aware
of the trier award and I started doing
some investigation and preliminary
research to find out what other public
gardens were doing and as part of that i
emailed 400 US public gardens i sent a
news letter out to be GCI which is the
tenant gardens Conservation
International they have 700 members
across 118 countries I correspondent
with began which is botanic gardens of
Australia and New Zealand and through
all of these communications virtually no
one had anything going on with her but I
did get a lot of feedback I got a lot of
emails back saying we don't have
anything but we're really interested we
don't have something but we're thinking
about incorporating permaculture
sometime in the future so that made me
realize that it wasn't just my own
personal interest and the interest of
the students and their teachers it was
really more than that and there was this
interest in the public garden
so I formulated by my sort of my
research objective and really what I
wanted to do was look at that area where
chroma culture and public gardens
overlap actually it's much smaller at
the moment than what this Venn diagram
illustrates that gap or that overlap is
quite quite small so in order to make
the research more meaningful and round
it out I wanted to look at what public
gardens were doing in Australia and
museum we had new zealand especially
because that's worked on the culture was
born and I figured if anyone was going
to have exposure to permaculture would
be the public gardens in Australia I
wanted to look at what they were doing
that they might not be calling from a
culture but might have some really
similar content and by the same token I
wanted to look at permaculture
organisations that might have similar
missions to public gardens but we're not
public gardens who were doing some kind
of environmental education and this
whole context was framed within the
foundation of education so I was looking
at education perspective not from a
landscape design perspective and not
from a plant selection perspective
that's really the length that i was
using so over the course of six months I
started out in Australia I was there for
two months I moved to New Zealand for
three and then Trinidad for what I
already mentioned Australia is the
birthplace of permaculture New Zealand
was the one site the one international
site that I got a response back pain yes
we're doing something with permaculture
not only are we doing something but
we've been doing it for 10 years that
was the that's the site of the
sustainable dockyard and then Trinidad
actually might buy original third plan
was to go back or third destination was
to return to South Africa and revisit
that program that I started with
unfortunately logistics did not pan out
something at the last minute and I was
able to find a contact in Trinidad that
was willing to take us on and who had a
great education and outreach component
to their permaculture work all right so
we have to start sort of with the basics
here what is permaculture and I pose
that question to you and I'd like to see
a show of hand if you think you
generally know what from a filter it
how many people would feel comfortable
sharing a definition with the rest of us
all right it's about for about four side
I'm not going to put any of you on the
spot but for those of you don't feel
comfortable sharing a definition you're
not alone one of the first and
continuing things that I realized over
my trip was that most people i encounter
particularly in the public garden world
are not familiar with permaculture or
have misconceptions about what it is a
lot of people think this is going to be
fair there are several triste you might
appear this way there you know this
association with hippies and abandon a
mainstream society and the base where
they're off at the fringes is what a lot
of people contract but I'm here to try
to dispel the myths that that seem to
abound wherever permaculture in which is
also one of the things I spent a lot of
my time doing while I was traveling just
to start with a little history bill
mollison and David Collbran Co found in
the concept in the mid-seventies is a
response to industrial agriculture
permaculture is an amalgam of the two
words permanent and agriculture or
culture and six on three core epochs
which will switch on in a minute it's a
big lens it accesses both traditional
knowledge systems and modern technology
so it's not about abandoning all that is
good with Western science it going to
the past it's about taking and picking
choosing what's relevant for each
particular design and utilizing that
it's also relevant to any scale a lot of
people find permaculture or feel things
that permaculture it's really only
translatable to large scale but it
really isn't it can be a large rural
farm it can be suburbs it can be very
urban even to the way someone patio
garden there are lots of definitions of
what permaculture is and as my
disclaimer I'm just going to stay I
don't expect to comprehensively explain
permaculture people take 2 and 3 B
courses in tempo please understand what
it's all about but I do want to share
with you Phil mollisons definition which
I've sort of turned out here which is
the conscious design of productive
systems with diversity stability and
resilience and these are three key words
that really exist in any permaculture
system working with nature mimicking
nature rather than working against
natural systems focusing on generating
the multiple functions of the system and
exposing those and utilizing those
rather than on individual elements
within a system and this is my
your piece of it thoughtful and
protracted observation rather than
thoughtless and protracted action
to start my trip off I took a one-week
teacher training and permaculture course
at the criminal to research institute at
they tuna farm Dave Jenkins was the
assistant instructor and his definition
Kurt's a design science that emulates
nature's resiliency to provide for
people so again not providing for people
it's an important piece we're coming
back to these three core ethics that
permaculture sits on care fever care of
people and fair share or equitable
distribution of resources so in
permaculture you can get a really deep
into permaculture without talking a
whole lot about these because these in
general are assumed to be common human
ethics that we can all pretty easily
galvanized around so again this you can
find online this is actually from
permaculture principles calm so I don't
want to go spend too much time each one
of these 12 principles together create a
permaculture framework to work within
but examples of what these individual
ones are include observing and
interacting obtaining a yield producing
producing the waste trying to close that
loop so that you're not importing
resources and then exporting waste
you're trying to cycle that right on
your site using and promoting
biodiversity and using the edges and
valuing the margins so the question I
commonly got was what is different about
permaculture from these other things
like old shadings like to rain
and I my garden organically as a
permaculture and I go back to the
original definition if it is complete if
it's a conscious design of productive
systems that featured and promote
diversity stability and resilience then
it falls within that permaculture Velva
okay and I love this quote by Dave
Jackie we create ecosystems we do no
matter what whether we think we do
whether we know it so why not create
good ones here a couple of different
examples with the kinds of ecosystems
and added for permaculture is our clean
common sense design so some people say
well I study holistic management or
cultivated ecology or sustainable
horticulture you know I don't see how
that's really different from from a
culture and I say those are multiple
words that all get the same core values
they all come back to this smart
cleaning common-sense design all right
so now we're back to the quiz let's
green about a ticket I'd love to just
have a couple of volunteers raise your
hand and shove it up they eat your waist
yeah there's some purple we'll wait for
you to provide your own food
they can control pests without without
without needing to use chemical guys did
great they scratched with their feet
they dig they aerate until the six pack
with their beaks Muzak rubs other paths
they fertilize with their manure and
scratch that in they produce a yield of
eggs and if you eat it they're meat and
if you needed their feathers but a
chicken itself is not really maybe green
so it might be a trick question it's not
really permaculture ticket but observing
the chicken and what she does naturally
and harnessing that behavior creating a
design system that harnesses the joy and
what she wants to do what she's already
doing that is permaculture so here is an
example of a permaculture system this is
the sustainable backyard in Hamilton
this chicken tractor which is a movable
chicken head the base of which is
designed to perfectly fit the raised
garden beds this is rotated around the
garden bed so the chicken the chickens
can do their work and providing
by the way that's Heidi the head and
that's a real for real chicken so just
to give you a quick picture of where I
went down along he started up here at
they tuna farm up to Brisbane down
through Sydney Melbourne Adelaide and
down to Hobart New Zealand I was
primarily up in Hamilton which is the
site of the sustainable backyard did
some pecan trips out here and then over
the holidays zip down along the coast
visited the Dunedin botanic garden and
flew out of christchurch trinidad tiny
island turn it on in to dig our way down
there here's a blow-up version stayed in
Freeport and the Botanic Garden was
right up here just a quick overview of
the students 66 you can read through
these I just want to give you a
definition of public gardens is the way
I am referring to it and this talk which
I am just saying for this talk because
it's different all over the world but in
this case I'm really distinguishing
public gardens and gardens that are
currently gardened so I'm not talking
about community gardens for school
gardens or other kinds of publicly
garden spaces when I refer to public
garden I'm talking about a garden that
you would most likely think of as a
botanic garden whereas an arboretum a
garden that has a permanent collection
that has a mission statement that has
paid staff that has a session clan
there's a lot of other criteria but for
our purposes I think
suffice so I visited a lot of public
gardens a lot of other kinds of gardens
we did three whooping sites worldwide
opportunities on organic farms by the
way if anyone has questions at any time
to shaman try to try to move through so
and basically that is a loose
international network of national
organizations that that matches
travelers with farms in exchange for
labor for room and board and learning
opportunities all right lots of stuff in
lots of beds did a few whose paper and
one radio interview helped me design a
website for the Hamilton permaculture
trust lots of chicken
also for permaculture farms a couple of
them didn't do anything with education
but they were such incredible examples
of permaculture and so I'm going to
start out just highlighting a couple
botanic gardens that stated they did
something with permaculture so Brisbane
was the first one and Royals has mania
Botanic Garden the two of these Gardens
had the same basic approach which was to
hire permaculture educators to come in
and lead one off permaculture workshops
record for two maybe two times or they
may offer a series and the public garden
devoted some space to that endeavor and
help with marketing they didn't really
engage in any of the direct education it
wasn't a consistent part of what they
had to offer for their educational
courses at the Tasmanian Botanic Garden
the peets veggie patch was a long time
running television garden show so a lot
of people came just to speak heat patch
and they that garden was built on
organic principles and they did feature
confrontation but beyond that it was
pretty standard however it is the only
botanic garden during my full travel
that I've seen a chicken tractor at all
so now sits in front of human history of
don't think it wasn't used for education
purposes someone said it was staff
members
this is adelaide botanic garden they
weren't currently doing anything with
permaculture I couldn't help it include
this shot of their barium which is
probably the most besides ours of course
beautiful or barium I've ever seen all
of the plant material as specimen just
look like works of art and gorgeous
jewelry they had 300 varieties of apple
wax wax apples and it speaks to their
commitment to biodiversity and they
really try to showcase that for their
booklet but this is the most exciting
parts because this is the site of their
future kitchen garden demonstration area
over the next couple of year actually
within the rest of 2011 they're working
on finalizing their design for this and
they hope to break ground on it in 2012
and permaculture will be featured as
part of that it's not going to involve
the whole design but in one bed within
the whole kitchen garden will be devoted
to demonstrating permaculture principles
all right so I'm just gonna hit the
highlighted ones here most of the
gardens had no stated from a culture
city but it doesn't mean they weren't
doing anything this is the Melbourne
Botanic Garden huge commitment to
children's gardening brand new garden
had a really nice funder and adjacent to
the discovery garden was a kid a
children's kitchen garden here's a
demonstration of their worm farm highly
productive they run lots of summer camps
and school programs through here and add
me to that you start in bed to teach
teach kids about growing food and doing
so sustainably a nice large meeting
space for children to gather and in the
back you see a rain barrel and that is
that is interpreted so students and
teachers can learn about why it's so
important especially in Australia to
harvest read this quote struck me in
particular combine the useful with the
ornamental William guilfoyle who is the
second director in the late 1800s built
a volcano structure to harvest rainwater
to supply the botanic gardens with
especially during drought season which
as you probably know is a big deal for
Australia but this really struck me
because it came at a time when I was
grappling with a lot of resistance to
permaculture based on aesthetic and this
idea that permaculture is really
and you know it's great for those people
but it's not going to work for my
partner this is that volcano if you can
see they recently refurbished it and
replanted it be interpreted it they have
some quite a bit of interpretation
explaining the processes at work what
kind of biofiltration is happening and
one of the highlights I thought of the
garden was this ski high which was right
out in the middle over a main path and
there were science and he placed around
saying she said it when they when they
swore they then you know follow the
storm and put set up new signs but
rather than trying to pull it down and
not only do they have signs warning
people they have signs interpreting how
important these are explaining to the to
the public the importance of those beads
so it's really a great teachable moment
and a beautiful study
ok this is mount annan botanic garden
unlike any Botanic Garden I've ever seen
1,100 acres the original director was
concerned that the city was going to try
to pull when reclaim some of that land
so he decided to develop it and for
completely disparate corners of the
garden meaning that you really actually
can't walk through the garden unless you
want to take all day from sunup to
sundown so people drive people just
drive through the garden they don't
actually get out of their car and so
there's a lot of interpretation that
happens around explaining and trying to
educate the public about what they're
seeing from the part which is something
I had never seen this is dead trees
provide beautiful homes with and watch
it you're a musician that's that what
studio films mount annan it's about an
hour train ride south of Sydney so
Sydney has those three Gardens is
fitting Botanic Garden on sperm on which
i'm not going to show you here and how
to end it they're all clustered right
around thinning it's a suburban it's in
a suburban area they also have a big
idea garden where they focus on reduce
reuse recycle and the message there
really is about what you can do at home
repurposing old refuse big focus on worm
come about worm composting and
composting and something unique about
mount annan is that it sits adjacent to
the MacArthur center for sustainable the
day and their focus the center's focus
really is on a very holistic sustainable
living model so they're talking about
housing and
the water transportation and gardening
but but they do the whole umbrella so
they do partner on some school outreach
and activities and they do a lot of
Tours and pair up to market what they
have to offer seven school groups come
to the garden they can do both they can
go and look at the big idea garden and
then come over to the center so this is
the permaculture garden at the center
although the volunteer who was the main
gardener there doesn't think it's
permaculture and we chatted about that
and she said permaculture was really
about you know just you just drove Steve
everywhere and that's not work so you
know she is a much better idea which is
to actually plant things where they go
together well and I think that's
probably perma built in Maya and my way
here is just a demonstration of their
worm farms christchurch by the way the
garden is okay after the quake and we
were we were gone after that although
the downtown is just ravaged i spoke
with bright emails last week action for
an update and the don thomas still kind
of in shambles and blocked off
this is the cafe the restaurant in the
garden and it is provisioned almost
exclusively with produce from the garden
which is adjacent and it's a beautiful
garden and they actually have some
features that you might more commonly
see in permaculture Gardens like the
step stop tires lots of inter planting
to poly cultures and also really
pointing out to the visitor the
importance of looking at this insect
plant interaction and why they've had
certain why they choose certain stats
and they have a swimming pool so now
we're getting the sustainable backyard
this is really the place they spent the
most time this is the Hamilton garden
which is a really unique public garden
that focuses on cultural gardens so this
is the Indian char garden the italian
garden the modern American public least
favorite garden I don't know if it has
to do with that there's Adirondack
chairs over here anyway japanese garden
chinese and while i was there they were
getting ready to open the first
traditional ahmadi garden in the world
and i got to plan sweet potatoes in
there which are kuma which is really
very special that's of your anointed
grandson so one of the things so anyway
you should know that this is sort of
what Hamilton Gardens is is about it's
about these beautiful cultural gardens
and the sustainable backyard fits right
in there one thing though is it's very
hard to get to the sustainable backyard
once you have made of to Hannah Hamilton
Gardens you really go down a very long
winding maybe that's the only sign
pathway and so you get to walk through
this right now while I'm talking to you
i did a questionnaire while i was there
and i asked people for feedback about
the garden and a huge problem was just
finding it you know they said we just
never would have found it we just
happened to stumble upon it through this
backdoor and access with a huge issue
and that other gardens I've looked at I
found that to be true as well this was
the sign posted on the wall garden right
outside of the sustainable backyard so
you saw his first and it went up about
five days after I arrived and it stayed
up the whole time so I don't know if
they're just spraying it all the time or
just been extra safe or what but that's
what that's what greeted people and then
once you were able to get by there you
made it to the sustainable backyard one
of the things that I got to do which I
was a highlight of my internship if not
the trip was to interview individuals
who had been impacted by the sustainable
backyard and subway one woman said she
had lived in the city and she had kids
and they were getting older and she
wanted to move to the country because
she watching her husband wanted to be
able to provide for them to be able to
provide food and go through and after
developing this relationship with the
sustainable backyard and visiting
multiple times and actually measuring it
out and realizing that the sustainable
backyard was no larger than her own
backyard if she pop in some of these
methods that she could also produced
and in fact it is full of life and it's
very different from any of the other
gardens in Hamilton Gardens lots of
birds and lots of insects lots of plants
and lots of people even though it is
pinched off in the back lots of people
do come through a survey was done by
Hamilton Gardens two years ago about
their favorite about the loop the
public's favorite garden and this came
up number third actually which is pretty
impressive on behind the Indians and and
behind the Italian garden is this was
the top choice so there's a big focus on
aquaculture this is a Zola which is a
great nitrogen-rich plant water plant
that can top dresser plans and also be
chicken everything they do in the garden
is interpreted these are water chestnuts
that went missing quite often
fortunately there were puppies those
always up missing a worm farm so you
start to see some consistent features
from guarding to garden center
addressing issues of sustainability lots
of Adobe structures that were all
community built but still a focus on
production this garden is designed with
a family of four in mind so that's what
it's supposed to be aiming to
demonstrate providing for this is a nice
example of a polyculture of scented
geraniums to confuse the coddling moth
therefore protecting the apple tree the
comfrey has deep tatras that mines the
soy the subsoil brings up the nutrients
make
available for the apple tree the apple
tree dropping beads and apples chickens
wandering around and helping to speed up
the whole process but anyway a very
supportive polyculture lots of flowers
for nice and sector e4 predators
pollinators again it's meant to be a
demonstration garden so there's a
laundry line up here place to hang out
which penis certainly did and really it
was beautiful that was one of the
questions on the questionnaire how does
this rage you have any comments or
suggestions improvements and only one
person out of 48 said I don't think it
looks very good I think it needs more
color but most people said it's very
impressive and I thought it was quite
lovely so we're looking here at a great
example of multi function is pergola
provide shade for visitors to fit and
rest underneath and support grapevines
and QB party q me and Annie hives as
well which the hives were always quite
active and also the pond was run by a
solar powered pump and that solar panel
has been stolen twice before it was
relocated right next to the high
pretty pleased that they thought of that
as a green permaculture again in
community build Adobe bench visitors
either loved it or they hated it this
here on the left is Chris who is a
really involved member of the firm of
Hamilton soma culture trust and the
designer of the garden although it was a
collaborative effort and then Joe on the
right she's a new gardener there and
this picture sort of demonstrates his
new collaboration one of the things I
was looking at was the partnership
between the Hamilton permaculture trust
eddakath garden and it has been streamed
through the years and this new gardener
getting her hands dirty and coming in
and learning about permaculture is
hopefully the opening of a new chapter
part of the issue in the past has been
that the garden the gardener hasn't been
trained and from a culture so there have
been discrepancies about how to keep it
maintained and running properly but I'm
everyone's hopeful that it's going
really far from here
just information about cultivated
ecology and permaculture people really
didn't read these signs they're very
text heavy but if people were interested
they were there one of the outreach
projects that Hamilton permaculture
trust who really originated the whole
idea of the sustainable backyard and got
off the ground did was work with local
schools and this path of school was when
they worked with so they did a whole
study on what is permaculture much like
we've already done here today and then
they went through a whole action plan
about how to realize their vision and
part of that was consulting with the
Hamilton permaculture trust and visiting
the garden and then they actually laid
out their plan put it into action this
with entirely child built okay the
teacher actually the principal we did a
tour around the garden could not
emphasize that enough he said this is
not an adult garden this is this is kid
and it's not pervy it's not maybe what
you would think of but he said it it's
well-built we wanted to they even use
pressure-treated lumber which you really
don't see with some lining that you
wanted to laugh so you know one of the
things about permaculture is there's not
always a definite right or wrong it's
not black or white every issue
and they use the chickens for sex
education so they also the Protoculture
trust also did quite a lot of community
outreach with adults and this is
demonstrating a basic tional change
project that was done again and of
course the course of just a couple of
hours taking a patch of asphalt and
turning it into alright so in trinidad
by the way these are the code so you
know where you are not sure we see it on
this farm that was 75 acres of
permaculture farm and their bread and
butter was really heliconia the only
time a little culture farm i know that
doesn't focus on edible crops so they
really they sold a lot of California
which was the flower of the last
political party and when they got Elstad
from power they said the sales have
really been down seven scuffling in
aquaculture again ornamental for the
aquarium industry that didn't work out
ecologically or financially so they're
in the process of unwinding not were
there a lot of what they do is focus on
water there in a big fire belt every
farm around them burns every year in
fact februari about the time you leave
februari early March this big time fire
season so a lot of what we did was help
prepare the property but they built or
dumbass a 15 dance on there
75 paper property every year they're
building new dams in order to hold that
water there and create fire breaks and
as a result their farm is the greenest
farm in the neighborhood this is their
swale it's kind of hard to believe
anything grows in it seems more to me
like you could throw a pop and grove
plant in it but that's their soil and
somehow they do manage to this is a new
fruit forest or food work near planting
but they do manage to grow these
incredible incredibly productive food
plans now this isn't the focus of their
operation that they are realizing that
that's the direction they need to be
moving in a way from ornamental question
what were the plants being grown banana
taro lots and lots of root crops cassava
lots of lemongrass papa pineapple it was
just a whole blend of beautiful tropical
foods and you say the farms around them
will burning potential burning or no not
intentional well I think a combination
of lack of fire preparation careless
neighbors burn piles on windy hot dry
days and just you know just the weather
patterns but it's very common to have
lots of fires throughout to be like with
you vigilant if you don't wander article
1 of the outreach projects that wats
amake does with students is studying
waterways and looking at how a piece of
trash they might go in there Creek on
their school grounds how where it goes
and what happens to it from there so how
they do that is designing these contour
models this is actually the contour
model of wasps amake but each student
did this type of model for their own
school grounds so that was one outreach
project they did another was was food
tree planting so what samake would raise
the young trees in their nursery and
then bring them out and work with the
students and come up with an appropriate
design and plant the trees and then help
with ongoing maintenance these are some
shots of a school garden that last one
is varying with like to play with a
hydroponic garden these shots really
demonstrate just
materials and gardening space that
otherwise doesn't have any you know any
earth we're talking about asphalt here
and creatively you know managing that
that challenge to maximize birthing safe
using containers innovative feds this
was actually an aquifer that's the
principle and this is an aquaculture
system where they were growing tilapia
and again the kids were very involved
every aspect of what they do in the
garden is integrated right into their
curriculum the tilapia were all dying
and they realized that all the leaves
from the tree overhead were falling into
the tank so they thought maybe that had
something to do with it so they cleaned
out all the leaves and they covered it
off and they realized that no one was
dying anywhere so so the kids get to
have a really increased learning
experience this was another school
garden that called itself a permaculture
garden she did a permaculture training
and that was all part of this bigger
project with with the schools and in
each each of these beds is basically two
and a half feet wide by maybe i don't
have twenty-five feet long and each
class or grade level who use it for some
different inquiry that related to
here's an example of what permaculture
bottom leg in a very urban setting this
was right outside of Sydney and
community centers part of the eco fair
brand newly built with a you know again
interpreter panel showing why they chose
to do certain things from two talks to
ground pepper copying the layers of our
bushland how they spread water through
the orchard designing a path that takes
you everywhere so just something that's
accessible for people to understand what
they're looking at and then at the fair
they have these lovely little models so
people could get a sense of what they
might consider doing in their backyard
all right so a few quick lessons from
museums i want to share one thing about
permaculture that makes it unique is
that it blends the old the traditional
with the new and it also really deals
with designing for time and
sustainability and permanent so we're
not talking about what can be grown here
today for tomorrow we're talking about
what can we grow in half we build the
soil and make it productive for a long
time to come and we went to a lot of
incredible museums i felt that new
zealand has some of the best museums in
the world i thought this was a lovely
way by the way public gardens are
considered living museum
by many and so they're very closely
related but i just wanted to pull and
draw from this field as well so i
thought this was a great way of compare
of bringing both together having those
old artifacts and relics next two
screens that could interpret them more
and give more detail about what people
were looking at so you'll get both there
this was your target tree of life in the
Dunedin Museum and I thought this is a
great way to classify organisms in that
area so each one of these little please
represents a different organism and a
human being is on the mammalia chart or
branch so we go in vertebrate arthropods
insects and that all dating sex with
your a great way to look and see how we
are all connected this was the best
exhibit called faces and I can't even go
into how great it was and why but i'm
just going to show you this one example
of time and this showing what one looks
like that's my youngest son that's him
at 47 this one is even scarier this is
72 years old my little eight-year-old
son and smoking his number now the
reason I'm showing you this is such a
great way that we can look into the
future and see something that can seem
so abstract right but when you look at a
picture like that it really
we're taking a very abstract concept and
making it very real and so I'd like to
just hose that as an idea for helping me
do more of that so you can't hear what
you staying but basically this is
able to pull this lever and see what New
Zealand looks like 60 million years ago
and then see what it looks like today
and see what it looks like 6 million
years into the future based on the
merchant of protection excite this is
the kind of thing that means you get
really good at okay all right so vegas
is bizarre this is probably the craziest
thing I've ever seen this you basically
look through these with a pellet you
know when you put the quarter news he is
long distance all right so you look
through there but instead of seeing a
long distance you see everything in the
museum and things are in there that
comes to life and you actually looked
like you you know it looks like you are
there and that person is better so it's
up to that and that's what's happening
I'm filming this through the legs
alright so he just disappears and you
can stand around and look at different
artifacts and hold it there and then it
comes to life it is unbelievable okay if
you're talking about education and
capturing people's imagination to see
what it was like back wed or to see what
it could be like
what an incredible we were just we were
all so all right all right so very few
public gardens are using in education
especially might have thought nommage
barriers it's a huge part of what i was
looking at during my travels stigmas and
aesthetics while we are at the top this
is winner of portugal's untidy garden a
word of this year I think probably that
I know and it's not just as set it
aesthetics but those two things together
and they're not unrelated to limited
understanding and accessibility this is
a pole I mean I'm not trying to say that
these are statistical because i'm
guessing that there are very many people
who took my pole on my blog but the
question here is just as the word
permaculture get in the way of
communicating however it is it to talk
about permaculture person to talk about
the principles that if you call it
something different is that is that
acceptable it's not just as well so this
is I don't know that I have the answer
for you but this is an ongoing
discussion risk aversion okay so many
people I spoke to in public gardens said
public gardens are so traditional we are
averse to risk you won't we cannot
tolerate it's just not in our history we
don't do it we don't like it you know
the reptilian complex is resistant to
change in our brain and I think you know
public artists aren't are very different
sometimes I mean we all we all have
those same brains and I think when
you're you know when your tradition is a
certain way it's very difficult to make
the change
so those are some barriers however some
public gardens are beginning to
recognize that there is visitor interest
in permaculture that it can support
ecological literacy it can support
public garden missions and then it also
maximizes resources when in time when
everyone pinching pennies and I love I
learned the Vegemite principles everyone
spread so Finley right you don't want to
feel a lot of it is because reading that
promo culture uses the resources that
you have so not talking about buying
expensive equipment or hiring you know
really specialized designers you're
talking about what are your resources
and that's a huge part of what
permaculture is about any design around
that around those resources that you
already have and to further this process
of integration public gardens can vest
and training and learning more about
permaculture partner with an
organization that is already doing so
and just learning from it from each
other in general learning from people
who are already doing it and those folks
who are using permaculture can be more
vocal about sharing what they're doing
one exciting development is that
permaculture may become part of
mainstream education and New Zealand I
interview both of these fellows
Christine's on the left his faculty
advisor to Nelson libo was a PhD student
his thesis is done dissertation is
looking at integrating permaculture into
secondary science curriculum all
throughout New Zealand so
is hopeful they decide they discovered
through the research that what's needed
is professional development and that
arena and so he's been working on
putting together contacts to get that
happening so we're talking about a whole
country possibly integrating from a
culture into their curriculum so it's
not maybe that friendly anymore this is
BGC I again Botanical Gardens
contribution international saying you
know tana gratins could be either as an
environmental sustainability how we can
reduce our impact on the environment
reducing the loss and reversing the loss
of biodiversity but there's no impetus
from within this sector now it's
published anything last year 2010
there's no impetus to lead the way and
so what do we do about this I would like
to propose that we just follow the
chicken so I've had a close there i'd
like to say a special thanks to the
drear committee for making this possible
was an incredible trip I really just
wish i had another hour Nina and Marvin
and Jeremy thank you so much they
haven't some criminal church rusts for
organizing my internship same with wats
amake durban botanic gardens for being
my original inspiration lots of
incredible hospitality I had great
editing help from Randy and then of
course my family my mom came a lot my
kids traveled with me my mom travels
been beginning for the first month and
then my husband who's here join me and
so we were all together for the last
four months
so thank you so much and I really like
in terms of well I think that
permaculture borrows from those ancient
traditional systems before industrial
agriculture I don't think they're
they're different I think the
permaculture relies on Mac and I'm glad
you brought that up because what I'm
meant to say when I was introduced in
the history is that while bill mollison
and David holmgren co-founded the name
permaculture they didn't just come up
with the idea babe built and garland
from build on and borrowed from lots of
generations of traditional knowledge
from a long time before that so I think
that's the relationship
the light examples you showed were
pretty small scale
I'm such a great question it's meant to
permaculture in theory it can apply to
any scale there's no automatic limit or
boundary to what kind of scale you can
apply from a culture too in fact when I
was in Trinidad this question came up in
a big big way there's a new Minister of
Agriculture and he's very interested in
sustainable agriculture and he wants he
wanted to see examples of permaculture
feeding lots of people not that your
family or mine but lots and lots of
people and so part of what I did was
reach out to my network of contacts
today do you have examples can you send
me any information you have you have any
studies and in research I need data that
can support you know that shows that
that it can we use on a really large
scale unfortunately it was very very
difficult the farms I know of largely
are used in part for education and
there's subsidized in some ways so
they're not burning all their bread and
butter through through the market
however well there's another example
that I had to cut out which I get it to
do called purple pear organic farm in
maitland australia new south wales it's
a 14-acre piece of land they farm all
the intensively on half acre they supply
26 yes they shares will be okay on a
half an acre and it's a very very
intensive about dala design these
chicken don't like crazy they are
collecting all of their data but they
don't actually have they're not
analyzing that they need someone
it's a big issue it's a big issue
because there's not the data in there so
to answer your question it can't happen
on a big scale but there's right now
there's data on individual aspects like
cover cropping and you know mulching or
using a certain kind of compost but in
terms of you looking at a whole system
it takes time to set it up and part a
permaculture even if it works right here
for me it's going to be very different
for you so it's hard to make this
comparison and still totally valuable to
have one example on a big scale that's
working this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu